one of the first steps in annotation is
to identify all of the genes within a
context and to determine the number of
isoforms of each gene remember that a
gene is a DNA sequence that can encode
at least one functional RNA and protein
product each gene in the Drosophila
genome has a unique gene name we will
use the genome browser to learn more
about gene structure go to the GEEP UCSC
genome browser gateway page and select
the dimalanta gaster July 2014
gene assembly enter contig 1 into the
search term box and click Submit the
default view shows the entire length of
contig 1 which consists of 11 thousand
nucleotides the flybase genes track
shows the dimalanta gaster genes on the
pack display mode with this view we can
see the gene and isoform names to the
left of each feature many evidence
tracks have different display modes that
you can use to control how the UCSC
genome browser renders overlapping
features for example let's change the
display mode for the flybase Gene's
track to dents and click refresh the
overlapping features are now rendered in
a single line to determine how many
genes are in contact 1 we will count the
number of features in the flybase Gene's
track each feature consists of one or
more boxes which correspond to exons the
lines that connect to adjacent boxes
correspond to introns a gene is composed
of a collection of boxes or exons and
lines that connect them together or
introns the gap between two adjacent
genes is known as the intergenic region
in this example contig 1 contains 3
different genes and each gene has
multiple exons and introns type contig 1
: 1 through 5,800 into the search term
box
then press enter to zoom into the region
where the first gene is located within
contact one change the display mode for
the fly based genes track to full and
then click on the refresh button now we
can see that there are three sets of
exons and introns that correspond to the
three isoforms of the gene CG 3 2 1 6 5
an isoform is an alternative form of a
gene that results from alternative
splicing or the use of different sets of
transcribed exons in the processed mRNA
each iso form of a gene has a different
mRNA sequence however some isoforms may
have the same amino acid sequences
because they use the same set of coding
exons let's look at the CG 3 to 165 gene
and examine the three isoforms in more
detail the labels at the left side of
the fly based genes track correspond to
the names of the mRNA in Drosophila the
part of the name before the last dash
corresponds to the gene name while the
suffix after the - such as RC RB or RA
corresponds to the name of the isoform
for example cg 3 to 165 - RC corresponds
to the C isoform
of CG 3 to 165 the arrows within each
intron denote the orientation of the
gene relative to the contig because the
arrows point from right to left
CG 3 to 165 is on the complementary
strand this means that the first
transcribed exon is located at the right
side of the image isoform C has nine
exons isoform B also has nine exons but
note that exon one is shorter this isuh
form has a different transcription start
site isoform a only has eight exons the
result of a mode of alternative splicing
known as intron retention let's zoom out
to the entire contact one and look at
the SPD - G enter contig one
into the enter position or search term
textbox and then press Enter
we can see that there is only one
isoform of this gene eisah form a
therefore only one kind of mRNA is
transcribed finally let's look at the
Trojan as indicated by the RA and RB
suffixes there are two isoforms of the
Trojan eisah form a and isoform B each
isoform has three exons but note that
exon 2 is longer an isoform b than an
isoform
a this is an example of another mode of
alternative splicing that is caused by
the use of an alternative splice
acceptor site